[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing albus dumbledore and what he
saw in the mirror of erised
now i know what you might be thinking he
saw socks
didn't he well it's actually not so
straightforward
when harry first discovers the mirror is
described as follows
it was a magnificent mirror as high as
the ceiling with an ornate gold
frame standing on two clawed feet there
was an inscription carved around the top
erised straw eru wait ub kafru
oit on wassi his experience with the
mirror was as follows
he looked in the mirror again a woman
standing right behind his reflection
was smiling at him and waving he reached
out to hand
and felt the air behind him if she was
really there he'd touch her
their reflections were so close together
but he only felt air
she and the others existed only in the
mirror mum
he whispered dad they just looked at him
smiling and slowly harry looked into the
faces of the other people in the mirror
and saw other pairs of green eyes like
his other noses like his
even a little old man who looked as
though he had harry's knobbly knees
harry was looking at his family for the
first time in his life
after losing himself in the mirror for
hours captivated with what he was
witnessing
dumbledore stumbled upon harry so back
again
harry said dumbledore slipping off the
desk to sit on the floor with harry
you like hundreds before you have
discovered the delights
of the mirror of erised it shows us
nothing more or less
than the deepest most desperate desire
of our hearts
he continued harry then proceeds to ask
dumbledore
what do you see when you look in the
mirror to which dumbledore replies
i see myself holding a pair of thick
woolen socks
one can never have enough socks he
continues at this point
harry returns to bed and it is revealed
that when lying in bed it struck him
that
dumbledore might not have been being
quite truthful as an introduction to
dumbledore is pretty telling
an evasive answer yes but one given
kindly and with his classic
whimsical sense of humor that stops
harry asking any more questions
so what does this mean what did
dumbledore actually see
it just so happens that in the most
recent film fantastic piece the crimes
of grindelwald
the mirror of erised resurfaces and we
see none other than a young dumbledore
standing in front of the mirror faced
with another man this man is of course
gelet grindelwald
grindelwald was of course very impactful
in dumbledore's life
and the mirror depicts the pair engaging
in a blood pact
the blood pact represents the pair
swearing that they would never fight
each other
something that wasn't entirely upheld as
we know that in 1945
the pair have an epic face-off in which
grindelwald's reign of power is brought
to an
end but just because that's what
dumbledore saw when he was young
that doesn't mean that it's what he saw
when he was older grindelwald isn't the
revised answer to this question
so in his old age what did he see
socks grindelwald something else
it has since been revealed in an
interview with jk rowling that
dumbledore
in his later years would have seen his
family
alive whole and happy aryana
percival and kendra all returned to him
and aberforth reconciled to him
this makes sense given the advice that
dumbledore gave to harry when he saw him
gazing into the mirror for
perhaps far too long dumbledore's most
important words to harry with regards to
the mirror were as follows
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
and i feel that this hits particularly
close to home for him given his history
i think the dumbledore perhaps lives in
regret regrets stemming from his
obsessive pursuit of the deathly hallows
and subsequent neglect of his family
perhaps the gentleness with which he
tells harry not to come looking for the
mirror
is driven by the fact that he too knows
what it's like to dream of seeing a
family again
whole and unharmed we know that
dumbledore had a troubled upbringing
with lots of controversy surrounding his
family
in the autumn of 1892 at the age of 11
albus began attending hogwarts
when he first started attending hogwarts
he had a bit of a hard time this stemmed
from stigma surrounding his father
percival who was sent to azkaban for
attacking three muggle children
percival's actions were in response to
muggle children in his hometown
attacking his daughter and albus's
sister ariana
people were under the impression that
the dumbledore family hated muggles
albus included this made his formative
year at hogwarts difficult
when albus graduated from hogwarts in
june 1899
he returned to his home of godric's
hollow to be with his family
after the death of his mother kendra
albus mother died in a tragic magical
accident
caused by his sister ariana who had
difficulty controlling her magic
after being attacked by muggles the same
attack that sent albus's father to
azkaban
albus being the eldest sibling knew that
he would have to take care of his
younger siblings
particularly ariana who had problems
controlling her magical abilities
it was during this time that albus
became close with gelat grindelwald
the boys grew close and devised a plan
to lead a wizarding revolution
that would effectively put an end to the
international statute of secrecy
breaking down the secretive divide
between muggle and magical world
when dumbledore's brother aberforth
learned of what the two boys were up to
he openly expressed his disgust with
their plan this would eventually lead to
a considerable amount of tension
between grindelwald albus and aberforth
grindelwald at his boiling point
used the cruciatus curse on our fourth
and at this point
alpha stepped in to defend his brother
at the end of the three-way jewel
between the wizards
albus's sister ariana was killed in the
crossfire
this effectively put an end to the
relationship between grindelwald and
dumbledore
and the two parted ways this also
destroyed albus's family entirely
his father was in prison his mother was
dead his sister was dead
and he no longer had any sort of a
relationship with his brother
but while it is widely regarded that
dumbledore's response to harry of
socks was an outright lie perhaps it is
just one aspect of the truth
after mentioning socks to harry he says
the following another christmas has come
and gone
and i didn't get a pair people will
insist on giving me books
perhaps socks are symbolic in that they
are representative of something
warmer something closer to home jk
rowling has always put a good amount of
emphasis on the connection between warm
homemade clothing and a loving family
case in point the weasleys
the weasley children are inundated with
handmade jumpers
and while they look cozy they are really
just symbols of love
of family so maybe dumbledore's answer
of socks
isn't so far from the truth after all
and that's it for this video
if you guys enjoy the content please
remember to like the video and subscribe
to the channel
until next time you're a wizard harry
you